as our cities become increasingly
congested with more and more people on
the move governments have to come up
with new solutions to improve traffic
flow and these days they're digital this
brand-new software is helping Hamburg to
improve the coordination of its
construction sites we're very pleased
we've had some astonishing results the
program is very intuitive it's very
similar to a smartphone or a tablet
anyone can use it it's very on
problematic and we're seeing a big
improvement in coordination let's see it
the software shows where a construction
site is planned if it looks like the
plans will cause traffic snarl ups
building work can be postponed
or bundled with other projects DeMatha a
disruption lesson in Hamburg traffic
lights and signals are already
coordinated digitally with technology
that optimizes signal timing to create a
succession of green lights for city
buses the traffic control centers
software shows how best to keep the rest
of the traffic flowing in the mornings
there are lots more cars and motorbikes
heading into the city as opposed to out
of it so signals are programmed to
optimize traffic in that direction
justice was induced adopting the Hamburg
is a pioneer in the field of smart
mobility in 2021 the city will be
hosting the intelligent transport
systems world Congress over the next few
years the local authorities will be
taking action to ensure residents spend
as little time as possible stuck in
traffic
the main focus is communication between
traffic lights and cars signalling to
motorists when lights are green the
Green Wave concept will be replaced by a
system providing information on traffic
lights including a crossroads
so that approaching cars don't have to
stop and start
the most dependable way to avoid traffic
jams is by rail those who don't have a
station on their doorstep can travel to
and from one with four wheels Hamburg's
overhead rail system is also linked up
to car sharing schemes a scoop moment on
I there's an app for Hamburg that shows
what public transport options are
available where the nearest car sharing
station is the nearest underground
station over ground station and the
distances between them in we want to
create a platform where the entire
process is seen - from leasing to
registering and paying completely going
[Music]
the inhabitants of big cities need to be
able to move about efficiently and also
get along together at the Hamburg
HafenCity University researchers have
developed digital models to analyze
behavior patterns such as where people
tend to congregate yeah hop first of all
we research how public squares work we
track people who are out walking their
dogs shopping hanging out to see her
public places function we collaborate
with companies and other research
institutes who also have an interest in
public places working well and
attracting people for the university
floor dadada and for often building
contractors can therefore see if their
projects meet criteria and compare
potential sites in terms of advantages
and disadvantages proximity to a
Research Institute or an airport for
example digitalization gives city
dwellers new opportunities to enhance
the urban experience